reflective views and opinions of 8 news
now or nextar Media Group
I saw a tremendous rage there were
several incidences where he came into my
office in a rage
tonight on politics now Rita Reed is
running for Clark County public
administrator her boss is accused of
murder she talks to the 8 news now
investigators about her decision to be a
source to the victim of that crime
journalist Jeff gearman selling
themselves to Latino voters we speak
with voters about why some are switching
parties for the upcoming election
piles of money are being spent on
Nevada's biggest races we break down
who's spending the most in Nevada's most
hotly contested senate race
[Music]
eight news now this is politics now
[Music]
thank you for joining us on politics now
I'm John langler right now Clark County
public administrator Rob Tellis is
accused of murder the victim reviewed
Journal investigative reporter Jeff
gearman who was investigating telus's
office Telus was elected to oversee an
office of eight people the number two
person in that office is Rita Reed she
beat Telus in a Democratic primary and
is now heading to the general election
Dayton is now investigator Vanessa
Murphy spoke with Reid about her
decision to run and the turmoil she's
endured
after years of working through processes
and trying to find a solution and we
just felt that well we we knew an
election was coming up and he was most
likely going to run for reelection and
there was a concern that he was going to
be voted in to have another four years
in that office and I myself and others
just felt that we had to do anything we
could
legally morally to
um to
try to get the word out to the voters to
the community that this was just a very
toxic situation and to try to remove him
from office did you ever feel a physical
threat from him there I was very
intimidated I think many people were
we would always remind each other just
watch your back just keep an eye out
just be safe so he said all the things
so we had that in us that we were very
uncomfortable but I think it was more
that especially in the last few months
since the story came out that um
there might be some kind of a
altercation of some sort or there might
be a verbal lashing or something from
him or others in the office he has
attacked you and that you had a motive
this whole time
um and because you're running for his
job can you just address that
um I'd be happy to
um through the course of the past three
and a half years in the past two years
specifically when other members of the
department started being targeted more
uh regularly and more severely in our
opinion severely apparently not high
enough to meet the legal level of
hostile work environment but it was
hostile for us to come to work
um we were talking about options and
talking to you know making those
conversations with the county and HR
different complaints and hearing back
that he was elected there was nothing
really that they could do he was elected
he was elected he was elected so
naturally as 2020 was growing closer so
this is in 2021 probably late 2021
summer of 2021 we're starting to be very
fearful that he's going to run for
reelection
and um that most likely he would he
would Prevail he was um had name
recognition by that point he was an
incumbent Democratic incumbent and that
office is historically Democrat
um and um
so we just felt that that he was going
to get another four years
and that was just
something we had to we felt we had to
try to stop if we could um in fact John
Cahill had asked me to run for office
before he you know as he was ending his
final term and I just felt I was just
good as a support I didn't need to be
the face of the office I'm a worker bee
by nature and I um
I felt comfortable in the role I had and
I felt that I was good there and
somebody else that really wanted to get
out there with the public be the face of
the office that would be fine with
Jeff's stories weren't about politics
they weren't a boss it's in our office
is not political
individuals die in our community every
day we get new referrals every day to
handle the property of individuals
we don't ask what party they are we
don't ask their families what party they
are we serve all the people
of all parties and all Races
nationalities I mean we that's just what
our office does if a person passes away
in our community it doesn't matter it
matters who they were but to us we're
going to handle that case no matter what
Reid is facing Republican Patsy Brown in
the general election the public
administrator's office we should point
out does handle the Estates of people
who pass away when a relative or Heir
cannot be found meanwhile though
taxpayers are still paying Rob tell us
his salary here's Vanessa Murphy again
with more on the effort to put Telus out
of his job
the Clark County District Attorney's
office is seeking to remove Robert teles
from his position even though he's in
jail accused of murder he still is the
Clark County public administrator and
he's still getting paid do you
understand the charge Robert tell us
appearing in court briefly Tuesday
morning as the DA's Office charges him
in connection with the murder of review
journal investigative journalist Jeff
gearman D.A Steve Wolfson says his staff
is also asking a judge in civil court to
remove the elected official from his
seat right now Telus is still getting
paid his 120 thousand dollar salary
what's he can't perform if he's
neglectful in his job he should be
removed Telus has been in custody since
September 7 and is being held without
bail until at least his next court
appearance on October 26th we tried
asking tell us if he'd resign after we
learned about the DA's effort to remove
him from office he refused to sit down
with us after his court appearance
[Applause]
tell us will now be represented by the
Clark County Public Defender's Office
reporting in downtown Las Vegas at the
Regional Justice Center Vanessa Murphy 8
News Now
a hearing on the case is now set for
September 28th now you heard of
Vanessa's story that Telos makes a
six-figure salary so why you may ask
does he get a public defender that
taxpayers pay for well the Clark County
Public Defender's Office says it is up
to the court to decide whether a
defendant qualifies
in other news the Republican National
Committee says Clark County has turned
over poll worker information this after
they filed a lawsuit now we're still
waiting for Clark County to confirm this
information but the RNC was requesting
the names and political affiliation of
County poll workers it argues the
information is public record since poll
workers are paid with tax dollars
initially Clark County declined worried
about harassment and privacy the RNC
requested the data because Nevada law
says poll workers cannot only be from
one political party it has promised
though not to release the information
publicly
this election year one in five Nevada
voters will be Latino that has both
political parties doing whatever they
can to try and earn their choice and
there has been a bit of a shift in a
recent Emerson College poll of Latino
voters here in Nevada the economy driven
by inflation and housing those were the
top issues as you see on your screen
there voters were split on who they
thought could handle inflation Moore
actually chose neither party than
picking one Republicans have made ground
though with latino voters in the past
few schedules the past few Cycles rather
and that includes Las Vegas Lydia
Dominguez who says she was Democrat most
of her life but now she's switching to
Republican
it wasn't just overnight
um but I was I didn't know I was
conservative until I really looked at
myself and looked at my values and said
I don't believe in this I don't believe
in in abortion I don't believe in having
you know to medicate your children to
change genders I don't believe in this
movement anymore
Democrats still hold a registration
Advantage among Latino voters they're
trying to keep it through phone Banks
and Outreach now this video you're
seeing here was provided by the campaign
of Senator Catherine Cortez masto Pablo
Leos is a new Citizen and construction
worker he voted for the first time in
the June primary and is making phone
calls for her campaign
I understand who is on my side who works
for me uh who works for the Latinos and
you know I think when when once I found
a a candidate that brings the whole
human Community up and don't put it down
I think
that's what makes me become a Democrat
Latino voter registration groups predict
a five to six percent increase in
participation this November
Senator Cortez masso's Republican
Challenger is Adam laxalt and his
campaign released this new ad
Joe Biden and Democrats have dismantled
border security causing a crisis of
human trafficking crime and lethal
opioids Biden's allies won't admit they
opened our borders the borders
and again that is an ad from uh the Adam
laxalt campaign it focuses on drugs and
crime and accuses Senator Cortez master
of refusing to secure the Border
certainly lots of money is going into
the Nevada Senate race so far incumbent
Senator Cortez masto has outspent laxle
by a wide margin ad impact reports this
race has the second most money spent
Nationwide 130 million dollars so far in
the general election so let's take a
quick closer look at who is spending
that money the Democrats main pact for
the Senate majority you can see here
26.3 million dollars and that's followed
by the Maine Republican pact just below
it and then Senator Catherine Cortez
masto's campaign also has a sizable
fundraising lead Adam laxalt's own
campaign is only spent about a quarter
you can see way down here a quarter of
her total so far going forward Democrats
have more ad reservations already booked
in the senate race you see there 47
million dollars in reservations compared
to the Republicans 27 million of the 31
Congressional race is ranked as toss-ups
at Impact says the most spending has
been in Nevada's Congressional District
3 between Democrat Susie Lee and
Republican Challenger April Becker 25
million dollars has been spent in that
race
next on politics now the latest group to
request an audit at CCSD
plus working on the river we asked
Senator Jackie Rosen about the latest
negotiations overcome
while switching to the battle
welcome back to politics now
Democrats in the Nevada legislature are
joining Republican calls to audit Clark
County School District assembly woman
and ways and means committee chair
Maggie Carlton says they want to audit
The District in the next session which
starts in February and one of the big
topics is always school funding back in
2019 lawmakers in Carson City reworked
how schools are funded in Nevada and
they want to see if it's working
Republicans have called for an audited
CCSD for years including gubernatorial
candidate Joe Lombardo CCSD hasn't been
audited by the legislature since 2004.
falling grades across the Clark County
School District where our main focus of
this week's board meeting a grading
reform committee made up of local
principals presented a plan to try and
bring grades back up the proposal
includes a more balanced grading
schedule removing bad behavior from the
grading process and a new standards
reassessment policy there was no vote
taken this week though you can take a
closer look at this proposal at
8newsnow.com
from what to do about the Colorado River
to abortion and money in politics this
week our Washington D.C correspondent
basil John spoke with Senator Jackie
Rosen in her DC office
are Democrats trying to come up with an
alternate number that you think could
get passed or what do you think the
compromise number would be you know I
support the law as it is in Nevada and I
support what's been the status quo for
the last 50 years let's be clear that
Mega Republicans their entire goal is to
take away what's been a woman's right
for 50 years this law went into uh into
effect when I was a teenager so my
entire adult life we've had this
protection and now suddenly my daughter
has less protection than I did my whole
adult life we need to protect women's
ability to choose the health care that
is right for them and the privacy of
their physician or provider's office
that's the bottom line I want to ask you
about the Bureau of Reclamation saying
that the Colorado River States need to
cut another two to four million acre
feet of water used by next year but they
have in the weak states to cut it are
you in the delegation talking to other
states for the Bureau of Nation about an
agreement or how much we'll have to come
yeah of course here in the United States
Senate uh us our Senators that are part
of the Colorado River compact we've been
discussing issues I know that the states
the governors been in collaboration but
what I do want to say is Nevada gets the
smallest amount of water from the
Colorado River and we've done more than
our share of conservation but this is in
all of the above kind of a fix we need
to collaborate and work together I was
proud that with the inflation reduction
act we were able to include 4 trillion
excuse me four billion dollars excuse me
for money specifically to work on
drought resiliency what does that mean
water is life we need it to live we need
it to grow our food
water is life and so we have to be sure
that we're working on every single way
not just to conserve but with smart
farming there's other one other part of
the legislation and it would require
super Pacs and certain other groups that
assume the donors who contribute to ten
thousand dollars or more to them during
an election do you think that it's
necessary to be uh as Clairvoyant as
possible when it comes to where money
comes from sort of some people who wrong
well I can tell you that for dark money
in politics you don't know where a lot
of the money's coming from for someone
against someone who's uh talking about a
subject so anyone can come in create
these dark money super Pacs and try to
influence an election uh influence a
vote and so I think transparency is
really important I can tell you it'd be
really important to me to and citizens
united
I have been advocating for that I think
we need to get that dark money out of
politics and have more transparency I'm
all for that
house lawmakers passed that presidential
election or form act this week the
Senate still needs to vote on it part of
it sort of cleans up potential ambiguity
in the election certification process
soon to be former Republican
congresswoman from Wyoming Liz Cheney
was the guest speaker this week at the
Nevada State Dinner Gala hosted by the
Vegas chamber out in Washington D.C the
outgoing congresswoman talked about
everything from the war in Ukraine to
the upcoming election Cheney is most
recently known for her work on the
January 6th committee she also did a
fireside chat with former Nevada
Republican congressman John Porter the
gala capped off a busy few days for the
Vegas chamber where they added a new
topic to the agenda trying to save the
shrinking Colorado River
fraud accusations against former
president Donald Trump next on politics
now the role his Las Vegas property
plays in a lawsuit from New York's
attorney general plus every team every
time they try and kill it it pops back
up Nevada's latest move to keep nuclear
waste from Yucca Mountain
[Music]
you're watching politics now
once again Nevada is trying to stop the
proposed Mountain nuclear waste dump
State leaders call it a zombie-like
project Nevada attorney general Aaron
Ford is asking the nuclear Regulatory
Commission to deny a license Yucca
Mountain as you'll know is about 60
miles Northwest of Las Vegas back in
1987 Congress designated it as the only
site that could be considered for a
nuclear waste dump since then late
Senator Harry Reid and other politicians
in Nevada have done whatever they could
to keep the plans mothballed right now
the U.S has no long-term plans for
managing nuclear waste much of the
storage is done on site at the country's
92 nuclear reactors the recently passed
inflation reduction act does include
incentives to create new nuclear energy
plants
a major 250 million dollar lawsuit filed
this week by New York's attorney general
the defendant former president Trump and
members of his family they're accused of
fraud here's basil John once again
we are filing a lawsuit against Donald
Trump Wednesday State Attorney General
Leticia James announced the state of New
York is suing former president Donald
Trump the civil lawsuit also includes
three of Trump's adult children and the
organization they operate for violating
the law
as part of his efforts to generate
profits for himself
his family and his company
the lawsuit alleges the trumps were
involved in large-scale fraud Often by
overvaluing assets like buildings and
golf courses to deceive Banks to lend
money to the Trump organization a more
favorable terms than would otherwise
have been available to the company James
says the three-year long investigation
also found the former president and his
family violated several state laws
including
falsifying business records
issuing false financial statements
insurance fraud the Attorney General is
Seeking a 250 million dollar judgment
and restrictions on future business the
family can conduct in the state in
response Donald Trump called the
attorney general a failed official whose
lack of talent in the fight against
Crime is driving people and businesses
out of the state and Donald Trump Jr
said quote Leticia James doesn't care
about the law she's a Dem activist who
only cares about politics Trump's legal
team added they look forward to
defending their client from claims they
call meritless reporting in Washington
I'm basil John
Las Vegas is Trump International Hotel
in Tower was included in that lawsuit
that law Tower rather is partly owned by
Phil Ruffin it opened back in 2008. the
lawsuit specifically mentions Eric Trump
talking to an appraiser who put the
value of that property at 111 million
dollars that was less than the
outstanding loans at the time the
lawsuit claims the value was
miscalculated between 2013 and 2016.
Dakota let's go places
you're watching politics now
Democratic governor Steve sisalak says
nevadans can now use a free digital
discount card for prescription drugs
could save up to 80 percent on certain
medications the array RX card can be
used to get a discount on any FDA
approved drug State officials say
there's no membership fee there are no
age or income restrictions and
citizenship is not required
taking care of yourself and prioritizing
your health shouldn't leave you bankrupt
and I will never stop at my mission to
bring more Affordable Health Care
Solutions to all nevadans
we'll put a link to download the card at
8newsnow.com meanwhile a spokeswoman for
Republican gubernatorial candidate Joe
Lombardo said in response quote under
Steve sisalak two million nevadans live
in an area without enough Primary Care
Providers and Nevada has a shortage of
more than four thousand registered
nurses
[Music]
this week in what to watch will he keep
his job Clark County public
administrator Rob tell us has a hearing
on Clark County's effort to kick him out
of office tell us as you know is accused
of murdering review journal
investigative reporter Jeff gearman we
will be at that hearing next Wednesday
and we will certainly let you know what
happens
also next weekend marks five years since
the one October shooting we will carry
ceremonies being held across the valley
live on channel 8 that evening and have
special reports all next week as we mark
five years since the darkest night in
Las Vegas history
that'll do it for us here on politics
now we thank you so much for watching
all the latest political news at
8newsnow.com we're back with you every
Saturday thank you for watching
[Music]
foreign
[Music]